Peggy's 16 hi everyone its Dan Mejia a
Blee assisted by battlefield expert
study and in the second part of our
guides of battlefield 5s classes and
combat roles we're going to be taking a
look at the Recon and support classes
first up I think he wanted to show us
the the pathfinder combat role that's it
that's a recon combat role right yes
so the Pathfinder is more of an
aggressive Scout so you're trying to get
in behind enemy lines and you do this by
using the spawn beacons and with the
Pathfinder class you get the advanced
scouting trait so not only can you spawn
on your own spawn beacons but you can
actually spawn on any of your teammates
using spawn beacons as well so it's a
really useful tracer huge advantage and
you also gain additional squad points to
give you supplies whenever someone in
your squad spawns on your spawn beacon
it seems to be a role that would work
better if you're in isolation because
you need to be fast and I guess a little
bit stealthy as well to navigate your
way behind enemy lines but ultimately
your actions are benefiting the squad as
a whole for sure so you're being much
more sneaky you're trying to give your
squad a place to spawn but after you've
already checked out the area
so the the second combat role that's
currently in the game for the Recon
class is sniper so the sniper trait
allows them to have the eagle-eyed trait
which means that you spot enemies
whenever you shoot them so as soon as
you hit an enemy with your rifle it will
instantly spot them for your entire team
so that allow them to then finish off
the final kill you also get the expert
marksman trait which means that you can
hold your breath for longer and then
whenever you get a headshot whilst
you're holding your breath you actually
replenish your breathing keeping your
scope steady for a longer duration as
long as you're continually hitting
people in the head what you're trying to
do with the marksmen tree is you're
trying to pick off those snipers and
support players that are sitting back
prone with their bipods and making sure
that your team isn't getting hit by
those units
our final class the the support class
first up the engineer combat role so
with the engineer support class the
support class in general can rip is the
only class that can repair vehicles but
with the vehicle fixer trait you can
repair vehicles and you can build
fortifications faster than there's a
poor class and then you also have the
heavy weapons trait which means that the
static and auxiliary weapons take longer
to overheat so if you're a tank gunner
it means that you will have an advantage
over another class when you're using the
static weapons so you're playing a
supportive role to the vehicle players
you would suppress the people the
student at the tank and then maybe you
would then go behind and repair and
whilst they're putting their heads down
to make sure they're not getting shot
and so we come to the second combat role
for the support class this is machine
gunner how does this differ from the the
engineer so with the machine gunner
you're all about the automatic machine
guns so they get a bullet storm trait
which means that you cause more and
receive less suppression and suppression
in this game is visual so it makes it
harder to see what's going on around and
when you suppress them with the focused
fire trait on this class when you
suppress enemies after you've shot a few
rounds they'll actually be spotted for
your entire team so even if you're
missing even if you're not very good at
aiming this is the perfect class to sit
down shoot around the enemies and then
the rest of your team can see exactly
where these people are and finish them
off this is the aggressive support
player so this is the player that maybe
wants to run and gun not play a passive
role wants to be up there in the
frontlines
but at the same time still being able to
give people ammo this is why the class
is so versatile well on that we are
going to end it there that is your guide
to the support and recon classes study
thank you so much for your time it's
been great and don't forget to check out
our previous video if you want to know
more about the assault and medic classes
thanks for watching
played on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]